and I think I have cynicism at my core
and so when I'm around people who don't
see the world that way
it's iy2 it-it's hard I get more nervous
I I don't feel like I can relax and just
say anything and they'll understand the
the layer of cynical critique that is
just a part of how I look at the world
and then then I have to be very careful
around them it's like being around an
aunt and uncle at a wedding and they go
what tell me about this breaking bad and
you going well yeah it's not really for
you but you know there's a lot of
violence and you know you don't really
I'm not gonna just relax and tell you
what I'm thinking cuz you're a nice
person you live in a nice world the
world you see is a nice place with good
people with good intentions and that's
not how I see the world okay so I'm
happy that you exist and and I'm not
trying to dissuade you or teach you
anything right god bless you for seeing
things that way we need people like you
more than we need people like me and I
don't want I don't want to you know what
I mean I let's go through your head
every time yeah and so when I the last
day that the whole crew on that film was
together um it was a wonderful moment
were Steven Spielberg thanked us all and
told us how great we were and then we
went to a restaurant where everybody was
talking and enjoying the experience we
just had and I got to hang out with
Meryl and I had a great time and totally
relaxed and just laughing and were you
upset with yourself that that's because
she's cynical and so like it's like I
was right yeah right like I knew like oh
I mean obviously I should be intimidated
by her a massive talent and resume and
just who she is right but way less
because I could just I could say
anything and not feel like she might not
understand
the point of view that I'm talking from
it might hurt her feelings even to here
are ruder or harsh comment it wouldn't
she's really a sharp kind of harsh harsh
person